good morning Hank it's Tuesday the
favorite downs movie finished shooting a
couple days ago so I am home I'm tired
and a little bit sick and as you can
probably hear my voice has been rode
hard and put away wet but I'm happy to
be home and so grateful to everybody who
works so hard on Paper Towns movie so
this is a map of New York created by the
general drafting company for the gas
station so I suppose I should explain
for our younger viewers that this is
essentially like a static version of
Google Maps printed on a very large
sheet of paper but anyway this
particular map is interesting because
we're wait where are you oh there you
are so this map is kind of famous to
cartography nerds and also to readers of
Paper Towns because just north of a
little town called Rockland New York it
contains a glow New York I go was a town
made up by the two guys who created this
map Ernest G Alpers and Otto Lindbergh
they took their initials together mixed
them up and made a globe and then they
put their little fake town in the middle
of nowhere at the intersection of two
dirt roads and the Catskills they did
this to protect their copyright map
makers have always created these little
Paper Towns or paper streets so that if
they see them on someone else's map
they'll know that they've been robbed
anyway flash-forward like 40 years after
the first general drafting map with
agloe New York on it Rand McNally makes
a map with agloe New York on it when
General drafting calls Rand McNally to
be like we're gonna sue you Rand McNally
says no no
agloe is real because people kept going
to that intersection of two dirt roads
in the middle of nowhere expecting a
place called agloe someone built a place
called agloe essentially Hank the story
of iPhone New York is a story of a
fiction that became real now I would
argue that this happens to fictions and
constructions all the time like I
remember one time in college I told one
of my professors that things that are
constructed aren't really real and my
professor was like well this chair is
constructed but if I hit you with it it
is going to hurt the truth is Hank the
way we imagine the world does end up
shaping reality and the book Paper Towns
is about how we hurt ourselves and each
other when we imagine other people as
less than human or more than human but I
guess what interests me most is with it
like are incomplete imaginings of other
people and they're incomplete imaginings
of us end up shaping our lives really
profoundly so anyway back in 2008 I
published a story about how like the
merely imagined can in my opinion become
really real and then agua New York which
had originally been fictional and then
became
real and then sort of fell into
disrepair and disappeared again kind of
became real again leaders started making
pilgrimages to aglow they found the site
of the former aglow General Store one of
them even made a fake historical marker
which I guess come to think of it as
kind of a real historical marker and
then six years later largely thanks to
readers continuing to care about cue and
Margo and aglow people in Hollywood
decided to make a movie and it all
became real again in a way I got to meet
all of these people that I'd imagined
and go inside of their houses and visit
agloe New York with them thank the
journey of this too this has been the
weirdest and most wonderful part of what
has been a very weird and wonderful year
for me personally so I just wanted to
take a second to thank everyone who's
made Paper Towns real by virtue of
reading it and in turn made agloe real
again of course I know that Ed will will
again cease to exist someday as
everything does but I think it's pretty
cool that together we've made it real
for a while thanks for that I can't even
begin to explain what a gift it's been
for me Hank I'll see you on Friday